Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome to the bonus stream!
It's a little bit of a super unexpected gorilla stream.
Is it really be... Is it really unexpected when I sort of told you guys I was gonna do a gorilla stream anyway?
This is more of a chill stream because I wanted to mix it up with the back-to-back Apex streams that we had all of a sudden.
So like to make it up to you guys, I decided to just like do a bonus stream today!
Do an extra bonus stream and just hang out with you guys.
Because both Apex streams, they were both like collabs.
I didn't get to really interact with you guys.
I didn't get to talk to you guys or like fuck around a lot with chat.
Because I was like super... Well, I was semi-focused.
Like, who are we kidding?
I was not super focused on the tournaments.
If you cast...
If you invite a call...
If you invite a content creator into these tournaments, you're never really super focused.
You're not really...
Okay, to be fair...
I'm going to practice more Apex though because I don't want to throw...
I don't really...
I don't really want to throw the challenger circuit.
To be fair, today's tournament was more about like games that were more fucking around than actual Apex.
And I'm not even actually serious.
Except for the time when Timmy yelled at me 30 seconds straight to fucking use my Q and shield.
And then...
And then I...
I did not do that.
That was...
That was a little embarrassing.
That was my...
That was my moment there.
In front of everybody.
Not just to you guys, but to the normies that watched Timmy as well.
That...
I was truly...
I was the...
I totally left a great impression regarding VTubers to Timmy's audience.
Truly...
Truly was the most impact I've ever had towards Timmy's...
Towards Timmy's like first impressions of me.
Definitely.
For sure.
I hope...
I hope he still enjoyed the time we had.
I hope he still enjoyed the time.
Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You paid the price for chicken and rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All that for chicken and rice.
Guys, I was off my groove.
Like...
You know, I didn't get to talk the drop before we start the game.
Look, I'm gonna make a hundred fucking excuses.
Because like...
As anyone that plays competitive FPS games before...
You never blame yourself.
You always blame other people.
And...
You make a hundred thousand excuses why you were not the problem in the video game.
So this was...
I'm gonna blame chicken and rice.
I'm gonna blame...
It messed with my groove.
You know, I didn't get the chance to like...
Get to know drop.
So I have to get to know him while we were playing.
And then...
And then I got messed up because we were getting contested.
So I didn't realize they were there.
And then...
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
And then everything went downhill.
All because of chicken and rice.
Every game after that went downhill.
It broke everything.
It fucked with everything.
All because of chicken and rice.
Every game after that...
Got fucked with.
Miki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is actually a zero copium moment.
Even if you didn't see that skin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alex, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
But yeah, I'm definitely gonna be practicing more apex starting tomorrow.
Because not only do I have the scars cup.
Also, yeah, because I also have the scars cup.
And it's a little bit more serious.
Because JP people do take like...
Like the tournaments I was in today and yesterday.
They were really like, you know.
We were all like fucking around a lot.
And it was all like for fun games.
But like the scars cup one is a bit more serious.
Um, like there's no like actual...
There's no like fun game modes.
They're all like...
Gotta try.
You actually gotta try guys.
We have to try.
I mean, I do try.
I did try today.
But I could have tried a little more.
I would admit.
I could have not tried to get to know Dropz.
And like have a conversation with him.
I could have just played the game.
Instead of having a conversation with Dropz.
But instead I got a little distracted.
Tried to have a conversation.
And I died.
I could have not had a conversation.
And just focused.
I would admit.
But I wanted to get to know them.
I wanted to get to know them.
I don't want it to be like never see you again.
Like...
Um...
Anyway...
After the scars cup we also have challenger circuit.
With...
Uh...
Wig and Tempo.
And I definitely need to try for that.
Thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Um...
Also I have the challenger circuit too.
And those people...
The people we are playing against.
They actually scrim.
And for those who don't know what scrimming is.
They actually like do like practice games.
Uh...
They do practice games.
Like...
You know...
Almost every day.
And then there's me.
I don't think I have to explain.
I don't have...
I don't think I have to explain more.
When I say...
And then there's me.
Um...
So I have to be less of a content creator.
And more of a like...
An actual player.
Uh...
You know...
And so...
So...
Oh yeah.
Also a really funny thing.
After the tournament.
Like...
Uh...
Jen Burden DM'd me on Twitter.
And like he followed me back on Twitter.
And he was like...
You're so fucking funny.
And honestly...
When like...
And...
Like he was like...
You're so fucking funny.
I had a great time playing with you.
And honestly...
If an Australian said that.
You know?
If an...
I think Australians are really fucking hilarious.
Because like...
I like...
I like groove with their sense of humor.
And...
I guess they don't...
They don't give a fuck.
They don't give a...
Australians like...
Australians say the wildest things.
And like...
Honestly if an Australian says you're...
You're really funny.
Like I take that as a fucking compliment.
And...
And then...
I told him.
I was like...
I...
Okay also by the way...
Like...
I know I only released like top 10 of who won the most money.
And...
And like...
And so like...
So I...
I know how much money I won.
And I won more money than Jen Birden.
I straight up told him.
I was like...
Oh my god.
I actually made more than...
Because like we joked about it.
When we had the game.
And I was like...
I actually made more than you.
This tournament.
Like I'm practically a pro player now.
And then Jen Birden was like...
Wait.
I made no shot.
And I made more than Jen Birden and Zero from Dark Zero.
Which was fucking funny as hell.
I honestly...
I thought it was so fucking funny.
I actually made more than Zero and Jen Birden in that tournament.
Yeah.
So I was like...
You know what?
I take that as a win.
I...
I take that as a fucking win.
Right there.
Man.
It's alright.
Just Australian things.
But I had a great time.
It was honestly...
Nice to finally...
I never played with Jen or Timmy or Dropped before.
So like it was definitely an honor to be able to play with them.
Even though for Dropped it was like literally one minute.
But like...
Even though it was only for a minute with Dropped.
That's alright.
But like Jen and like Timmy.
Definitely...
Oh yeah.
I'll be remembered by Timmy as the...
As the new cast of that wouldn't fucking listen.
The worst.
To be fair.
He had an actual real team during the other three strikes.
But then he got the same placement as us.
So in the end...
No.
He wouldn't have improved.
He...
Like whatever teammate he got after me did...
It didn't matter because he didn't even improve his placement.
I mean...
He was just...
Like...
Those two teammates that he had were 100% better than what like...
They were literally pro players.
Like he literally had another pro player on his team.
And...
Because of that they still got fifth place.
So what does that say?
What does that say?
I literally play just as well as having another pro player on his team.
Except I just don't know the difference between Conduit Q and Shield.
Like...
I just didn't know the difference between Conduit Q and...
Um...
And Newcastle Q.
Okay?
I'm not a professional player.
I'm a content creator.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
He should have said...
Newcastle Q.
I was literally waiting for the...
For the Conduit Q...
The Q incident.
I'll never forget it.
Also for those who are...
Uh...
For those who are new here...
Um...
If you guys didn't know...
I got partners.
I'm a partner with...
GamerSupps!
What does that mean?
It means like...
Not only do I get referral code, but I'm gonna have merch with gamer supps in the future.
Um...
And we're gonna have an art contest.
Uh...
To...
To decide...
What the merch is gonna look like.
Uh...
More details on the merch next week.
So you're gonna hear more about the merch stuff next week.
Like...
Not merch.
Sorry.
About the art contest next week.
And the prize pool is like seven thousand dollars.
So, I think we're picking 10 winners.
We're picking 10 winners and the total prize pool is $7,000.
So, I'm very very very very very very excited to see all the entries.
But yeah, huge shout out to Gamersupps for sponsoring 5k of the art contest.
And I'm putting in an extra 2k in there.
Just because I wanted to be able to pick more artists.
So, at first it was like...
The reason why I sponsored 2k more, like I added my own 2k in there.
It's because I wanted to have more chances to pick artists and stuff.
And I felt like, you know, I feel like there's going to be a lot of entries.
I want to be able to make it possible to be able to, you know, give you guys...
Just be able to, you know, give artists more chances to be picked.
Especially it's really good for like resume and stuff too.
If you're an artist that wants to put in your portfolio.
For like design work and stuff like that.
Like if you were able to... if you get chosen, it would be really good for your portfolio and stuff.
And you get money too!
And you get money as well.
So, it's like a win-win situation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tell me what do these gamersuppositories do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm not really good at shilling.
They sent me a $300...
Package.
For free.
Of like gamersupp stuff.
So, okay.
They don't... they go in your mouth.
By the way, you drink them.
It doesn't go anywhere else in any other holes.
You drink these.
It's powder.
That you put in your drink.
And then you put water.
Also, apparently the gamersupps like snack bars are really good.
I haven't had a chance to try it out.
But it was in that package that was sent.
And...
Because...
Okay.
You know what?
Clarify.
Because he said suppositories.
Like...
If you don't know what suppositories are, you have to specify where it's going to.
Anyway.
I was recommending flavors earlier on in the Apex streams.
And I...
The current ones...
I haven't tried all of them because it was a lot.
Okay.
It was a lot.
But there's...
The two ones I really like so far is the melon one.
I'm not going to read out the actual names.
Because like...
Apparently, people were telling me to try the guacamole one.
Because apparently the guacamole one is actually really really good.
But I haven't tried the guacamole one because of the name.
The actual name...
I don't know.
The name doesn't really appeal to me.
Like...
Everyone is like, it's legit really good.
You have to try that one.
This one's the best flavor.
But like...
But the name though...
Like...
The name though...
It's like in the sample pack too.
Like...
I looked at the sample pack because I didn't want to like...
I was lazy when it comes...
Because like...
There's one, you know, the actual powder stuff where you get a spoon and put it in.
But like...
I'm lazy.
I don't want to measure.
So like...
I've been like using the sample pack that they gave me as well.
You know, there's like the ones with the actual bins.
And then there's the sample pack they gave you that has like...
You just rip it and then you pour all of it contents in there.
And then...
I got...
I didn't want to get a spoon and measure it.
So I've been using the sample pack.
And in the sample pack, they have the guacamole one.
And I won't say the full name because like...
I can't.
I can't guys.
I'm like...
I can't.
I'm a coward.
I am.
But anyway...
Breezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But when is the review of the guacamole?
I haven't tried it yet.
I have...
I can't.
I...
Oh my god.
Literally, I've tried every flavor in the sample pack but that flavor.
And everyone says it's the best one.
They all said it's the best one.
And I'm like...
I can't.
Tell me how that tastes, chat!
Oh my god.
You know what?
Maybe I am great at shilling stuff.
Viva, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If I win the art contest, can I get my money in Canadian tire money?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lory Corrosus.
Guacamole.
Say it, doki.
Say it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zonderman.
Not very good at Googling.
Can you say the full name in Pig Latin for me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what you can do?
You can click on my link and just search up guacamole.
That's all you have to do.
That's all you have to do, guys.
Just search up guacamole.
Okay.
Anyway.
By the way.
One other shill thing.
The Lunar New Year merch is...
Pre-order is next... next week.
So make sure you grab it before it's gone.
Because everything but the...
But the red pocket...
The red pocket will be gone forever.
So...
So like...
If you guys want to grab some merch, some limited merch, make sure you get the Lunar New Year merch.
When will there be new merch?
I'm trying to wait until I send my first shipment of merch.
I haven't received my... our first...
Like the debut...
The old debut merch yet.
So the reason why there hasn't been any new... anything new in the store...
Or like anything...
I guess like other than that, I am planning on one day...
Releasing voice packs one day.
One day because there's so many things to do.
I'm so behind on so many things.
But like...
The reason why there's going to be a little hiatus with merch...
New merch orders...
Like not new merch orders, sorry.
New...
Merch releases is because I want to be sure that I've settled with the debut stuff first.
Like I shipped those out first.
Before...
Like I received them and shipped them out first before I think of new merch.
Just because like I don't want to like have like a bunch of stuff that's been on hold.
You know?
And everybody's like, where is our merch?
We've been buying merch for like three...
Four...
Three to four drops now.
Where is it?
And I'm like, please.
I'm still waiting on the...
It's on the fucking ocean.
It's on a ship.
And I'm still waiting.
Because it takes so long to travel and water.
It's like...
I have to wait like two months for the merch to arrive to me.
It's so long.
Bro.
Oh my god.
One time.
Okay.
This is recently.
Not one time.
Like right now.
Bro.
Okay.
So like one of my packages...
Because remember when I said I ordered like 50 at first to prepare?
Because I thought only 50 of you guys are going to buy my merch.
So like I ordered...
I pre-ordered 50 at first.
Because I was like...
How many people are going to buy my merch?
Maybe 50 people.
And it's been stuck in customs.
It's been stuck in customs.
And I have to go to the customs office to like unstuck it.
It's so fucked up.
And then I was like...
I was like...
Hey, can I like call...
Because they were like...
They emailed me and was like...
Hey, you have your package and like we need you to sign these forms.
And like do this.
And then I was like...
Okay, here's my information.
Because they needed one thing.
And then they replied back.
And they were like...
Never mind.
Go to their office.
And then I...
To settle all of this.
And then I was like...
Hey...
Um...
Where...
What?
First off...
Where the fuck is this office that I have to go to?
Like I was like...
What does that mean?
They're like...
Go to the office.
Like go to like this...
The customs office.
And I'm like...
Where the fuck is...
Where is the customs office?
Where?
And then they were like...
I was like...
Hey, I'm confused.
Um...
I've never done this before.
And can you give me this information?
Like what do I do?
Like who do I call?
And then they were like...
You can't call them.
Go to their office.
And I was like...
Um...
Where is the office?
And they gave me the address.
And then I looked it up.
The worst part was that I looked it up.
And they're closed.
They're closed on like Fridays to Mondays because it's a Canadian...
It's Easter.
It's fucking Easter.
So I can't do anything about it.
I was just like...
And then like the manufacturer...
They were like...
The manufacturer got back to me.
It was like a back to forth with them.
And then I was like freaking out.
And then the manufacturer got back to me and was like...
Hey, what the fuck is going on?
Like...
Um...
You're supposed to pay the custom taxes by the end of this month.
What's going on?
And I was like, by the end of this month?
Bro!
It's not!
It's Easter!
What do you mean?
By the end of...
It's Easter!
How am I... I can't even call them!
I was just like...
How do I even call?
They don't even take calls!
And I was like...
The guy literally said...
In the email...
They don't take calls.
What do you mean?
They don't take calls!
I was just like...
I can't even call them?
I have to be there?
And then...
And then I told the manufacturer...
I was like...
I don't know what to do.
They don't take calls.
Look at their office hours.
They're closed.
And then they're like...
Okay, we're gonna...
figure this out.
And they're like...
Oh, we got you an extension.
We extended it to Monday.
And I was like...
Monday?
It's still Easter!
I was just like...
What the fuck did I suggest Monday?
It's not gonna be open!
It's still Easter!
I was just like...
Bro, it's still closed!
And then...
I was like...
I replied back and I was like...
The office is still closed on Monday.
I don't know what...
Can you give me Tuesday?
I literally was like...
Um...
Can you...
Can you give me Tuesday?
The office is still closed on Monday.
Because it's Easter.
I was so confused.
I was like...
Don't worry.
We extended it.
I was like...
To what?
It's still closed!
Like...
I can't...
I just can't believe it.
I know I'm repeating myself.
But it actually blew my mind.
That they were so...
generous enough...
to extend it to Monday...
when it's still closed.
It was...
It was so generous, guys.
They extended it...
to a date where I still can't visit...
the office.
I quit.
I was just...
I didn't know what to do.
I was just like...
Tuesday, please?
Anyway, I'm like waiting...
for them to get back to me...
on whether or not...
I mean, what else can they do?
If they can't do Tuesday...
I don't know.
They're not getting my money.
I guess.
At that point, I don't fucking know.
So yeah.
Anyway, happy Easter...
everybody.
I hope you guys are having...
a great Easter.
Everything's closed for me.
But I hope you guys...
are having a better Easter...
than I am.
Apparently.
That's basically...
how my life is...
so far.
Um...
Also like...
Oh my gosh.
Funny thing is...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I saw in your post, re-debut your tomato form...
with a hat.
Is that...
toggle?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I told you guys before.
My...
My real form.
I still have my hat.
I can put on a hat.
Yeah.
I didn't know you...
I told you guys about this.
I just don't know where my hat is right now.
I didn't...
I need to ask my creator.
The one who birthed me.
Like...
Um...
If they can like...
find my hat... remake my hat.
Or find my hat.
I actually lost my hat.
I don't know where it is.
I actually don't know where my hat is.
But yes, I... I can...
Of course I can wear a hat.
It's a fucking hat.
Like, what do you mean?
You think the hat is glued to my skull?
I say as I can take off my hat on my skin suit.
Um... This one is.
This hat is glued to my...
Just so you guys know.
This hat is glued to my skin suit.
It's like sewed in.
Because like I'm wearing a skin suit.
So this one is like glued slash...
sewed in... into my skin suit.
But like...
I have multiple hats.
I have like a collection of hats.
And uh...
In my real form, I can wear that hat.
I just don't know where it is.
That specific hat.
I don't know where it is.
Um...
Miki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um... Hey, I have a serious question, Hey, I have a serious question, Dragons.
What game should I get my roommates to play?
As homies, as bros, as amigos, As ya know.
Um... As a bro?
Um...
Apex.
Bro, I don't fucking know.
You should play any type of game.
Like Monopoly, Or like It Takes Two, Which is not a board game.
Any type of board game.
If you don't want them to be your friend anymore.
Um... Mario Party.
Exactly.
Mario Party.
Stuff like that.
If you still want to be their friend...
Oh yeah!
If you don't want them to be your friend anymore.
Also play that cooking...
Play it up.
That ruins relationships.
That's true.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not to throw more on your plate, but are you still planning on opening a PO Box?
Also congrats on the gamer sub sponsorship.
Uh... GamerNade flavored.
When?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good question!
So the reason why the PO Box is still not open yet, Is because, um...
Mr. Man is opening a PO Box right now.
And...
Um... He recently moved.
And... Um...
We were dealing with the PO Box stuff.
And the reason why it's not open yet, Is because...
Um... Apparently the PO Box place...
Um... They require Mr. Man to be on a lease.
And...
I don't even...
Wait... Is he doing... Okay wait.
Um...
He is legally living somewhere.
Uh...
He's just... They're just...
Working on his lease right now.
Just so you guys know.
He's not living...
He's not living anywhere illegally.
Just so you guys know.
Like...
I didn't realize when I said that...
It sounded really bad.
It sounded really...
Okay.
Anyway... He is currently...
Cause he's like...
Rooming roommates with people.
So he is currently working on his lease at the moment.
So the moment...
He is on the lease.
He can open the PO Box.
Um... So do not worry.
He is living somewhere.
Very legal.
It's just that it takes time to be on...
I don't know how American... I hope I didn't fuck him.
I don't know how American living scenarios are.
But...
They're working on it.
The moment he is on the lease...
Um...
We will have the PO Box open.
That is what we're waiting on at the moment.
That is...
That is what we're working on.
And like... I asked him.
I was like...
How long does the lease take?
And I also asked his roommate.
Because like...
You know... Just in case.
Just in case.
And like...
The roommate said...
It would be like... It's like...
Don't worry.
Everything is going on track.
It would be...
It would be done either by the end of the month.
By this month.
End of this month.
Or beginning of the week for next month.
So...
So we're just waiting on that.
And in the moment he is on the lease...
We have our PO Box.
Because...
You're sending...
Remember... I'm telling... I'm reminding you guys this.
Is where Mr. Man lives.
And like...
So...
Near... Yeah...
So... It's...
I mean... We need his lease.
Anyway... I was just like...
Did I dox Mr. Man?
Well... Anyway...
Mr. Man is located.
And...
It's where he's located.
And because of that...
Um...
You're sending stuff to where he's located.
And so he can like...
Check it.
And then...
It's a PO Box.
So...
So basically... He is gonna be looking through the mail.
By the way.
We're gonna have like rules and regulations.
Regarding the PO Box.
So... One thing is... You can't send...
Send us food.
You can't send us any...
Liquids or food.
And then the other...
Thing is like... Um... We won't be accepting...
Any like... I think...
Any... I don't remember.
I just remember...
Any electronics.
Yeah...
We won't be accepting any electronics.
And also...
No food.
And like... He's gonna...
Be like... Screening everything.
For me.
Including mail.
So like... Your fan mail will be...
Read by him.
So like...
If you're writing me anything...
Make sure you're okay...
With him reading it.
I mean it's not new.
Okay guys.
I'm just saying... Like...
Before times... For my fan mail...
When you sent me fan mail...
They were also screened.
So like...
It's not like...
It's not like I was sent fan mail and...
And like...
Um... They didn't know...
What was in it.
It was also screened...
And read by others as well.
So like... I'm letting you guys...
Know right now... That...
Mr. Mad will be reading your fan mail.
And will be looking through...
All of the items that you guys are sending me.
So like...
Just go in there with that mindset.
If you're writing anything to me.
Or if you're sending me anything.
Yes!
You can write him a letter as well.
Chat.
You can also write him a letter.
If you want to.
Just make sure it's addressed to...
Mr. Mad and not me.
Okay guys.
Just make sure.
Breezy can I send a copy...
Of Shadow of the Hedgehog...
On my PS2?
Or you're going to send me a PS2 as well?
What am I going to play it on?
Breezy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
DDragon thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Anya thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Mad hiding from the IRS under Doki Bird on the lease.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But yeah that's like...
That's the current update regarding the PO Box.
We're working on it.
We're working on it chat.
We're trying our best.
We just have a lot of work to do.
Also it wasn't obvious.
Um...
We have a staff volunteer.
Uh...
To show me around SakuraCon.
So we had like...
We actually had like...
Uh...
We had a volunteer to show me around SakuraCon.
And grabbing me merch.
So yeah to all the artists that I met.
At SakuraCon.
Uh...
Thank you.
Thank you for drawing me.
And producing like...
Uh...
Producing merch for all the Ddragoons.
I really appreciate it.
Um...
Yeah...
I'm hoping to do that more.
So I could be able to...
Uh...
I guess like...
Have more...
What's the word?
Have more opportunities to visit other artist alleys around the world.
Um...
So I won't be like as limited.
So it was a nice experience to try.
To try out.
To see...
Try like with SakuraCon.
Being able to like visit a convention and stuff.
Being able to say hi to the artists and stuff like that.
And...
Like my merch was selling really well at artist alley.
Like I think like...
Two to three artists was tell...
Like for one of them my merch was sold out.
It was like one of the only one...
The only like keychain or charm that was sold out.
Um...
On day two cause there's a day three.
And like apparently they sold out on day one.
I was like really really surprised.
And then they were telling me that I'm like a best seller or something.
And I really appreciate it chat.
I...
I really really appreciate that.
Uh...
You guys bought like you know.
You guys supported the artists as well.
And um...
And that you guys like bought so much merch from me.
I really really really do appreciate that.
Uh but yeah.
One of the volunteers like brought me around on their phone.
Like one of the staff volunteers.
Um...
Like they were like they were boofing at the convention.
It wasn't SakuraCon staff.
But like uh...
One of like the booth staffs.
Like someone that was doing like these booths or something as an exhibitor.
Volunteered.
Like Mr. Man connected me to one of the staff that was um...
Exhibitor.
And they volunteered to like uh...
Show me around on their phone.
And like saying hi to people.
And like yeah.
It was a great great experience.
I hope I do...
I hope I can one day be like a convent...
Well I hope I can one day be like an actual convention guest guest.
So um...
That would be my dream.
Well not really dream cause like I've already done it before.
But...
Not...
Not a dream.
But like I hope one day like as Doki...
I can um...
Have like meet and greets.
Like official convention meet and greets.
And um...
Be able to...
Like as an official convention guest.
You know?
Like as a guest at the convention.
And uh...
Be able to meet you guys.
I really do hope so in the future.
Uh but yeah.
That was fun.
It was fun though.
Being able to talk to all the artists and stuff.
I still can't believe my stuff sold out.
I can't believe it.
I was so surprised.
You know?
Cause like I'm not under any company or anything.
I'm just me.
I'm just little old like...
Little Doki.
Like all...
All...
Little old Indie Doki.
Trying to make it in the...
No I mean I figured I...
I've made it before.
But like you know what I mean.
Just trying to survive out there in the Indie world.
It's always scary.
It's so scary being Indie.
Because you have to do so much stuff.
To be like I guess like relevant.
In the Indie world.
You don't have like a company or brand.
Like under you.
So then you have to...
You have to...
Like you know.
Have a brand that's like...
Able to survive as a solo.
Like...
I'm Beyonce.
You can say I'm Beyonce.
You did not.
You did not just call yourself...
Beyonce.
No way.
Okay.
I aspire to be Beyonce.
You're right.
I'm more like...
Okay you're right.
What's your name?
I'm more like the Spice Girls.
And I'm trying to be...
I'm trying to be...
Posh Spice right now.
You're right.
I'm behind.
I'm more like Posh Spice.
Trying to make it out.
Make it in the world.
After the Spice Girls.
After like...
Where's Beckham then?
Oh I want to be Sporty Spice.
But Sporty...
No I don't.
Because nobody remembers Sporty Spice.
What's her name?
What's Sporty Spice's name?
Everyone remembers...
Posh Spice's name because she married...
David Beckham.
But who the fuck is Sporty Spice's name?
That's right.
That's fucking right.
None of you remembered.
But everyone remembers Victoria Beckham.
Everyone remembers...
Victoria Beckham.
No one remembers...
fucking Melanie.
Whatever her name is.
And everybody knows Beyonce.
Everyone knows Beyonce.
I don't want to be Melanie.
No one remembers Melanie.
They have...
names.
I like how someone...
was like...
Melanie?
As a question.
You're not even sure of yourself.
That's the worst part.
Of her name.
You remember...
Because I literally googled Spice Girls.
I literally googled Spice Girls.
Because I was like...
Who were all the Spice Girls?
She was a badass.
You don't even remember her.
You just remember her as a group.
You don't even remember her as a group.
And that is why...
I am scared.
That is why...
Um...
Alright, anyway.
Or maybe because Melanie...
People know Melanie in the UK.
Maybe.
Alright, what songs has Melanie sang?
What songs...
has Melanie sang...
that you guys know?
That you guys...
That you guys remember?
That's not Spice Girls songs.
I saw someone was like...
I lived in the UK for 8 years.
And I don't even remember her at all.
Oh my God!
No, I don't want to be Justin Timberlake.
I don't...
What?
No, I don't want to be it.
Beyonce is like the most safest...
person out there.
I don't want to be Justin Timberlake right now.
I don't think anybody...
wants to be Justin Timberlake at the moment.
Beyonce is like...
She is like...
the perfect queen right now.
She is literally like...
Like in a perfect spot at the moment to be a person.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Names are useless.
We should all be serial numbers.
What the fuck happened?
Are you guys serial killers?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What happened to Justin Timberlake?
Well, he like...
Some stuff happened.
So what did JT do?
Well, there was a book.
That's all I'll say.
There was a book.
Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
If I can be a testament to the family's sales, I've been hard at work 100%ing my Doki Shrine.
And I've now purchased over 12 items from indie vendors.
I'm indeed my wallet hurts worth.
But you'll never get a better Doki Shrine than me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, yeah.
That is why...
That is why I want to be Beyonce.
She's the safest choice right now.
Or Victoria Beckham.
Because the...
Because like, everyone remembers Victoria.
Everyone remembers Beyonce.
And like, Victoria was so funny in that one documentary where she was like, I had it rough.
And then David Beckham was like, tell them your dad's car...
Tell them how many cars your dad owns.
I love that video.
That is actually the fun...
Bro, David Beckham was so real.
He was so fucking real for that.
Be honest.
What car did your dad drive?
You guys don't know that?
Oh my god.
Wait, let me...
Let me send that.
Okay.
Victoria Beckham.
Working...
Oh yeah, because she was telling people she's working class.
And then David Beckham was like, be honest.
Yeah, he definitely...
Yeah, he definitely slept on the couch that night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How was the tournament?
You had stuff to do and missed it.
Were you ever gay with Nico again?
The show with him was hilarious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think the tournament was really, really fun.
I definitely enjoyed the tournament a lot.
But I definitely will be tryharding more for next week.
So I'll be practicing more Apex.
Because I was like...
I've been slacking with my practice.
Because like...
I had a lot of stuff to do.
Like back to back to back to back.
But I'm getting a lot of things done recently.
And that... I was like super...
Like that took up most of my time.
And a lot of the things that took up a lot of my time is like...
I don't have to deal with it anymore.
So like...
I'll be definitely be practicing more Apex.
Because the next two tournaments are very...
Are very...
Actual tryhards.
Actual...
I have to try now.
I have to actually try.
But yes.
Also...
Nico...
I'm down to play with him in the future one day.
Just cause like...
Right now...
Like the reason why...
I haven't had really much like repeats.
Unless like...
They reach out to me.
Because I want to try and like...
Interact with as many new people as possible.
Every new...
Every week.
I don't know what would go me.
Cause we had a fucking long ass game to complete.
But...
But I'm trying to like reach out to new people.
Every week to collab with.
Cause I want to like...
You know...
Get to know more people.
And yeah...
I want to have like people to...
Collaborate with in the future with other games.
Any multiplayer games and stuff.
So...
Just slowly...
Meeting more and more new people.
Every week.
That's my goal.
Every week I want to meet a new person.
Today...
This week I met a lot of new people.
That's for sure.
But...
It was great to finally play with Jen.
I do want to say like...
I've always wanted to play with Timmy.
I've always wanted to play with Jen.
And...
Cause they're like...
Apex streamers I've watched.
You know...
Even back in the day.
I watched like Timmy.
And...
Jen a lot back in the day.
And so...
It was nice to be able to play with them.
It was definitely a...
A big help.
And...
I...
Dream come true.
Type deal.
Cause...
Oh my god!
Speaking of!
Okay, this is like...
A different topic.
But like...
Um...
I actually had like...
Uh...
One of my...
Super old friends.
I haven't talked to this person in a long...
Long long long long long long time.
But they were one of my...
Like...
Friends that I first made playing Overwatch.
They used to be like a big Overwatch content creator.
And like...
They reached out to me.
And was like...
Do you want to try out...
Like...
Do you want to go back to Overwatch?
And like...
You know...
Play?
And I was like...
First off...
And like...
Oh yeah!
He wanted me to come back to Overwatch and try out the Faceit.
And Overwatch.
For those who don't know...
Um...
Overwatch League is gone now.
And now they established Faceit.
Uh...
Which is like the new Overwatch League...
System?
I think?
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
I know like Faceit is like a CSGO thing.
But...
They made a Faceit for Overwatch Rank?
Isn't that for Overwatch Rank?
I don't know.
They made a Faceit for Overwatch.
And they like...
Messaged me...
They like DM me about it.
And was like...
We should do it.
We're...
And I was like...
I'm fucking...
And then...
And then I was like...
Bro...
I'm fucking washed!
I don't even have Ilari!
Or like...
Life Weaver unlocked!
Like what the fuck?
And then he said...
Bro...
LeMah...
I don't even have Ilari!
Wow!
I'm fucking washed bro!
What the fuck?
And then they were like...
No man!
It'll be fun!
So I haven't responded back after that.
But I think about it.
I think about it.
There's always...
I'm not giving...
Overwatch has too much of my money because back then I was a young fool.
Back then I was young.
Now!
Now I'm not spending money on Overwatch!
You need to know, I had so many Overwatch... the amount of money I gave Overwatch in name changes and accounts and loot boxes was way too many.
I am not fucking buying Ilari.
I'm not buying to unlock Ilari and Life Weaver.
I'll fucking play the game and unlock them if I have to.
And it's 100 games.
You need to play 50 games.
You know what I didn't realize?
Do you know what I didn't fucking realize?
You need to like... to unlock a character, you have to click on the character and then you have to click unlock.
Like you have to be like... you have to click on the character and do like... do the challenge.
For that character.
So cause I thought... I thought when you play games it automatically registers as like what the character... the support character.
I didn't realize you have to click on the hero and then click... you do the challenges for those heroes.
Cause I was like oh man I did 20 games.
Yay!
And then I clicked on Ilari and it said 0 out of 50.
I was like yay!
I did 20 games of Overwatch.
I was like... okay I didn't know it was 20.
I was like yay!
I played a lot of games of Overwatch.
I wonder how many games I have left to unlock Ilari.
I clicked on it.
0 out of 50.
It was... 0 out of fucking 50.
I was not happy.
I was not fucking happy.
And then I clicked on it and then I saw... I saw the number go up.
I saw the number go up after that.
Uh... plastic thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you.
Overwatch 2 changing the heroes to be all free.
No need to unlock for season 10 if I remember correctly.
Thank you for the magenta soup but thank you...
Oh my god wait when is season...
When is season... there's season... it's already season 10?
Didn't the game come out last year?
We're already on season 10?
Holy fuck we're gonna run out of fucking cosmetics.
Like...
What the fuck we're already on season 10.
Jesus Christ.
Bro I was looking at like the icons again.
That's just...
Not gonna lie no wonder like they changed up the rewards.
By the way Overwatch sponsored me and I'll...
I won't talk like this about Overwatch.
I love Overwatch.
Cause you guys started my career.
Um... anyway.
Um... anyway as I was saying...
As I was saying...
As... as I was saying...
Um...
I was looking at the rewards on Overwatch.
And I was so fucking surprised how much it...
Like how much it felt...
Like the reward system for top up...
Did you know they tried to make it like...
Okay I was looking at the icons...
By my silence yes.
I was looking at the icons and I was so surprised.
Okay before I mention more.
Before you guys were like wow Doki what a sellout.
I want you to say...
I want to say...
Everything I've said is not as worse as everything actual Overwatch content creators...
And actual Overwatch pros have said about the game.
And they have been sponsored and have been paid to promote the game.
Much more than me.
They...
They play the game professionally...
And some of them are like Overwatch content creators...
And I swear to god they have said worse things than what I've said.
Anyway...
Um...
As I was saying...
The fucking Overwatch icons...
I was so...
I was so fucking surprised.
I was so surprised because back then...
Back then in Overwatch like...
The early top 500 prizes...
Were really good.
Like the animated sprays...
And the...
And the fucking icons were really really fucking pretty.
Now...
Back in Overwatch 1...
It was like...
Now...
The final seasons in Overwatch 1...
It was like...
Weapons.
So like...
If you don't get...
If you don't get top 500...
You get like a normal weapon icon.
Like Tracer's weapon.
It's just Tracer's weapon.
But...
If you get top 500...
It's gold.
A weapon's gold.
But it looks so shit.
It looks...
Terrible.
It's just the same thing.
It's just a color change.
In the...
In the early top 500 days...
It's like a different scenery...
Of the icon.
And it actually...
And it has the top 500 icon.
And the top 500 icon...
Is like right in the middle.
Fucking huge.
It was right in the middle.
And then you can...
Also the jade weapons too.
Oh my god.
Why would I have a jade weapon...
When I could have a gold weapon?
Why do I want my item to be fucking green?
I'm sorry if your favorite color is green.
I'm so sorry.
What...
What do I want?
A green weapon?
Or a fucking shiny gold?
But...
But as a member...
As a member...
It's like...
Amazing.
Green is great though.
Speaking of members...
Guys please don't unsubscribe.
Please don't unmember...
Guys...
Please don't unmember.
Green is amazing in members though.
Like...
But as a weapon.
As a fucking weapon.
Speaking of members...
Don't worry.
I have a backup.
Guys, I didn't lose you guys.
Because...
We're gonna get new members.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Let's go.
Guys!
New member badges.
No.
No, you can't unmember.
Cause we're gonna have new member badges.
Woo!
Yes!
Green is a great color.
Woo!
Look at these new member badges.
Whoop!
Look at this.
That is yeah.
It's so much fun.
Guys!
Let's forget what I said before.
Let's forget...
Let's forget everything I said before.
And talk about how great it... I mean I have green eyes!
Chat!
I'm so happy.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Next, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Guys, look at that!
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god!
Not gonna lie.
Okay guys, okay, but like you guys are blue on my screen.
So like it's different.
Jen Robb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Green is a very... is not... yeah exactly.
Green is not a very creative color.
Saimi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa guys!
Look!
Look guys!
Look at the sub badges!
Also like to be fair, I told...
I changed the tomato to be like this.
Yeah.
This is like the edit I... I wanted to make.
So yeah, this is gonna be the new tomato icon.
Because I wanted all the... I wanted all the sub badges to be like universal.
Thank you to the artist that made the first tomato badge.
I really, really appreciate it for the placeholder.
So like really thank you.
But I'm gonna be changing the tomato.
Because like the tomato badge.
Because I want like all the badges to be universal and stuff.
So it's gonna look like this after.
It's gonna look like this later when it's done.
But yeah, actually like I'm really thankful.
The artist is like for the badges is one of my really good friends.
We've been friends for like...
Oh my god!
For like 15 plus years, I think.
And we've been friends for like 15 plus years.
Maybe longer.
But we've been artist friends.
We met on DeviantArt.
The cursed site now.
It has...
That site has gone downhill.
I'm surprised it's still around.
I'm sorry.
But I'm surprised DeviantArt is still fucking around.
But like we met on DeviantArt.
And...
We've been artist friends for a while.
When I was in...
When I was like you know...
When I started seriously YouTubing.
Like you know the last two years.
We actually lost...
Lost...
Not lost contact.
But we've...
We never had a chance to talk to each other.
During those two years.
Because I was so busy.
And...
I was really really busy.
And then...
They were really really busy as well.
Recently we started talking again after.
And they were like...
Yeah like I didn't really want to bother you.
Like you were so busy with work.
And like I was in there.
Like I was very busy with life as well.
So like I didn't really want to bother you.
I just wanted to watch you grow.
And then like they reached out to me after everything.
And was like...
Like sorry like never really talked to you.
After those two years.
And...
And like...
And then I was like...
Oh hey you want to still like work for me.
And you still want to like draw some stuff for me.
And then they're like yeah of course.
Because like we've always like...
They've always like done art for me.
And like we started like our...
They're basically the artists.
That I opened an Etsy with.
That's my friend.
We've been friends for 15 plus years.
And like...
And like I've always helped them with like money issues and stuff in the past.
So like I helped them grow their art more and help them find clients.
Like I was sort of like their agent.
I was sort of like their agent slash like manager in a way that like I helped.
Because they're very artistic in what they do.
They're like an untalented.
They're like an incredibly talented artist.
And I was the one that persuaded them to do like Twitch emotes and do like art stuff.
And like open like art stores and stuff like that.
And like to promote their art and help them get like clients and stuff for their Twitch emotes and everything.
And like I was like, you should do emotes with me.
Your art is so good for emotes and everything.
And then like, you know, and then I was like, do you still want to like we're talking.
And then they're like, yeah.
They're still trying to find like they're still trying to like figure out like their career and stuff.
Because they're trying to find like a stable job regarding art and stuff.
And I asked them, I was like, you want to, you know, do you want to do art for me?
You know, like I can, I'm looking for an artist for my sub badges.
Like, do you want to do them?
And they're like, yeah, of course.
Like I always do art for you if you want me to.
And I was like really happy because I always love their art as well.
They're very talented artists.
And yeah, so I'm really happy that they're doing my sub badges.
I even gave them like a really big tip because I was like, bro, I make like way too much money now.
Like, just take it.
Like, you're my homie, man.
You're my bro.
Just take the extra tip.
I'm so excited.
I'm really, really.
I'm really, really, really excited to the...
Catch up with them later too.
I actually had a lot of like old friends that reached out to me.
I haven't replied back to their text yet.
But like this is an old friend that like I basically got in one season in Overwatch.
I got like top 500 with her.
We would do a support.
We would do a support together in Overwatch 1.
And we got top 500 together.
And like, like she reached out to me.
And was like, hey, like we saw everything that's happening.
Like, like, like I'm sorry we lost contact and stuff.
Like lost...
I'm sorry like we didn't like talk to each other after Overwatch and stuff.
Like you want to just like, you know, hang out and just catch up and everything.
I was like, I haven't responded back.
But I thought like it was...
I went to like BlizzCon with her too.
That was how long ago.
It was.
It was so long ago.
Like she was like actually one of my best friends in Overwatch.
But we lost like...
We lost...
What's that word?
Lost touch?
Is that it?
We lost touch after Overwatch sort of died.
Not died, sort of died.
But like after like we both...
Like she had to go like to...
She had to like focus on studies and stuff.
And then I moved on to Apex.
They got lost contact.
Yeah, we lost contact.
But she's like actually one of my best friends in Overwatch 1.
And like it was really nice that she reached out to me and stuff too.
So yeah, I should text her back soon.
I should text her back soon.
It was just really nice, you know.
It was really nice that a lot of my older friends reached out to me to talk.
And just like wanted to hang out and stuff.
So it was really nice.
Yeah, I'm hanging out with my other like...
My other...
My artist friend.
The one that has friends who lived for 15 plus years.
Like tomorrow.
Just to catch up and everything.
Um...
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Contract Doki friend to do monthly backgrounds for you.
Give her more income as a plus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is so wholesome.
Love it.
And so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god.
I had like old Apex friends too.
Like...
Um...
This one...
Another Apex friend.
Oh my god.
This Apex friend that reached out to me.
They like...
They're in like...
I don't know if they're a doctor now.
But they were in...
A dentist?
They were a dentist.
They were a doctor.
They were in med school.
I'm trying to remember.
Fuck!
They were in med school!
But don't remember it was dentistry or...
Or...
Or a doctor.
But...
What are the...
It's the same thing.
They make a lot of money.
They make...
They make not a lot of money.
But one of them contacted me.
And...
Um...
When...
Uh...
One of them contacted me too.
To be like...
You wanna catch up and stuff.
And everything.
Um...
They actually...
It was...
It's really wholesome.
They were the ones that like...
Um...
Supported me and stuff.
When I...
You know...
When I first started seriously Vtubing and everything.
Uh...
When I like...
Had my big break basically.
And like applied to like...
Like VLogs.
And stuff like that.
Like they helped out and everything.
And was there like cheering me on.
So like it was...
Uh...
We lost...
Lost contact when I first started seriously working.
Just cause like...
Um...
It was very hard.
I think like...
When you...
When you get...
Become corporate.
It's very hard to keep in touch with people.
Um...
Because you're always so busy.
And I really appreciate all my old friends like...
Uh...
Reaching out to me and everything.
And like being very understanding that I was just so fucking busy.
I'm so fucking busy that I didn't have a chance to talk much to a lot of my old friends and everything.
And so it's really nice that a lot of them reached out and stuff like that.
And was super understanding with just me being antisocial.
Me being very antisocial and stuff.
So I really appreciate it too.
And yeah...
Kumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a doctor, I can assure you, Doki, no we don't make a lot of money.
Really?
It was all a lie?
Like...
Asian parents lie to me?
Why the fuck do they always want you to be a doctor?
It's always doctor or lawyer.
No way!
I always thought doctor or lawyer.
But you don't make a lot of money?
Oh my god.
I feel like the world is just a lie.
It's just...
To be fair, like...
It must suck to be a doctor in America because of student loans.
I would just say that like...
It must take you fucking years to make back the amount of money that it takes to pay off your student loans for lawyer and doctor.
Because there's a lot of schooling.
There's a lot of school involved to that.
Yeah.
I can't believe people would spread misinformation about it.
If you're a millennial right now...
Tell your children the truth.
Isn't that crazy?
Millennials now are having kids.
I'm sorry, millennials.
If you don't have a kid...
Millennials are at an age that they should have kids.
They should have doesn't mean they should.
They should have doesn't mean you have to.
Sorry, English is my first language.
But anyway...
Anyway, Millennials, don't tell your kids...
that being a lawyer or a doctor is a way...
Actually, you don't have to!
Because...
Being a millennial fucking sucks now!
Because like...
We can't afford houses.
And like...
Being a millennial fucking sucks because...
You know...
Housing market sucks.
We can barely afford anything.
So why can't you afford children?
Why the fuck will we be able to afford...
Children's universities?
Chat, university is very expensive.
Like...
Like, millennials can barely afford their own university tuition.
Actually, they can!
They can!
That's why student loans exist!
That's why student loans fucking exist!
They can't afford fucking...
Student tuition!
So why the fuck would they afford their kids' student tuition?
Don't tell them to be doctors or lawyers.
Tell them to go into computer sci-
Tell them to get into computer science!
Or en- Wait, actually, does engineers make a lot of money?
No, if doctors and lawyers can't make a lot of money...
So do engineers.
Comm Sci!
That's the way to go!
Com Sci!
Silicon Valley!
There we go.
We figured it out!
Com Sci is a new lawyer doctor.
Computer Science?
New lawyer doctor?
and...
Silicon Valley.
That's the goal!
That's so REAL!
I just got somebody like Software Science.
Computer Science here, it sucks.
Yes!
But u can pay- You don't have to get a master's degree.
And then get a doctorate.
You don't have to go to more school.
Computer science is flooded at the moment.
The thing is...
Okay, you're right.
Technical school.
There we go.
I figured it out, chat.
Tell your children to be plumbers.
And like...
To be plumbers and like anything else in technical school.
Trade school.
And trade school.
Because...
Oh.
I know I'm gonna reference a South Park episode.
Because nowadays...
We can't do shit anymore.
Like we can't...
We always need to call somebody to do stuff for us.
So now trade school is like much more demanding.
Because like trade school like jobs are now in demand.
Because no one wants to do things their own.
No one knows how to do shit on their own anymore.
Which is true because I'm that person.
I need to call somebody to do stuff.
Like I don't know how to fucking fix...
If you like watch a tutorial.
I still don't fucking know.
Like I'd rather call someone.
So trade school time.
Tell your children to go into trade school.
And the best part is...
When your child knows how to fix the toilet or do like plumbing.
And be a handyman.
You don't have to call anybody.
You can just be like...
I'm your mom.
I gave birth to you.
Fix my toilet.
And then like you know...
With a little bit of therapy for the child after that.
Like you just balance it off with therapy.
Because...
Don't talk to your child like that.
Because maybe you have to pay for your therapy.
But like...
So just say it be like...
Oh sweetie hey...
Mom's got a leaking faucet.
Do you wanna...
Do you wanna like...
You know...
Oh man...
I mean...
I try to call the handyman and everything.
But like they're so...
Backed up right now.
And it's like so expensive.
Son...
It's so expensive.
I just don't know what to do.
And then your son is gonna be like...
Don't worry mom.
I can come over and fix your...
What did I say?
Toilet or plumbing issue.
I don't remember.
Whatever is fine.
I can fix your plumbing issue.
Don't spend money on that.
That's why I went to trade school.
And then...
BAM!
You saved money.
We did it!
We solved the issue!
I'm getting PTSD.
Look at that.
That's what you do.
I'm giving you life tips.
Guys.
Write this down.
I'm actually giving you life tips right now.
Tell your children to go to trade school.
Instead of doctor, lawyer.
It's not worth it.
Student loan signed.
Ria, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nia, thank you for the super chat.
ComSci is also struggling because companies over expanded.
And now everyone's...
Oh yeah.
I heard everyone's getting laid off now.
It's much harder for new grads to get jobs.
I think like...
That's just not ComSci.
It's everything.
That's definitely not just ComSci.
Everybody's downsizing now.
Not just ComSci.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doki.
To remind me to not pay student loans.
I basically get free schooling.
Okay.
Legally.
Just pay for it when it's legal.
If it's legal and you have to pay for it, pay for it.
If like avoiding student loans is legal, please don't commit illegal acts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What was it?
Oh my gosh.
There was like a channel for illegal life hacks and stuff.
Oh my god.
I had a short rec...
I had like a short channel recommended to me.
And then it was like illegal life hacks with like SpongeBob and Patrick.
I don't know why.
It was like the channel was run by SpongeBob and Patrick AI voices.
Did you guys see that channel?
Or am I just a freak that got recommended?
I'm just a freak.
Let's see.
Sponge illegal life hacks.
SpongeBob.
It had a lot of subscribers.
It has like almost half a million subscribers chat.
This is like...
Okay.
This is like the channel...
The shorts that I kept getting like recommended for.
Like this one.
This is like...
Basically, they give you like illegal life hacks at SpongeBob Patrick AI.
I don't know why.
Unethical life tips.
Yeah, unethical.
Yeah.
It was like unethical life tips.
Life hacks.
And okay.
Like I gave an unethical life hack where I was like if you're giving a summon for jury duty, just like convince them that you have a bias.
Because like for those who didn't hear this because I said this on Twitch.
Basically, like to be in jury duty, you have to have zero biases.
You have to have zero biases for any...
For like the trial.
So you shouldn't have...
You should not swing over one or the other because if you have a bias, it will become a mistrial.
Because if you're like, oh, I knew it.
I knew that person was guilty the moment they walk in.
You will give up.
You will make it a mistrial.
Even if they are guilty.
Even if they are like guilty guilty.
You cannot admit that you have a bias towards something.
So like...
So basically, like, you know, if you get summoned to, you know, you just be like, you know, I feel...
Just be like, well, I, you know, I...
I don't know.
I don't think that person is a bad guy.
Even though...
Just be like, I don't know.
Never met...
I don't know.
He seems pretty innocent.
You know?
He seems pretty...
Seems pretty innocent.
And then...
And then the judge would be like, yeah, we're not picking...
They're not...
We're not picking this person to be on the jury.
But that's only if you really...
Just so...
Just if you really don't want to be on jury duty.
Just if you don't really want to be on jury duty.
To be fair though.
You can't...
I feel like...
Okay.
But to be like perfectly honest.
If you get somebody that doesn't want to be on jury duty on jury duty.
I feel like that hurts your case.
More than like...
More than...
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
The lawyers do.
But you have to convince the judge to take you.
But I just feel like if you hate jury duty and you get into jury duty.
I feel like...
Like, you know, it hurts the...
The...
The trial more than helps.
Because like they don't want to be there.
Like they don't...
Like they just don't want to be there.
You want people that actually are willing to, you know, like the justice system.
You know?
You want someone that actually likes the justice system and like has zero biases.
Because what if like...
Because the thing about jury duty is that...
By the way...
Like...
If...
Please correct me if I'm wrong.
Because majority of what I know about jury duty is from TV shows.
And...
And just like reading a little bit about it.
Like just reading a little bit.
So please, if you're a lawyer, correct me.
And or a judge.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
But like...
I'm assuming like the part that's right was where like the jury has to be unified.
It has to be like unified in their decision.
So I feel like, you know...
If you don't want to be in jury duty.
And like...
And the decision has to be universal.
What if I just vote for the majority?
Are you nameless?
Yeah.
What if I just vote for the majority because I want this to fucking end?
Like...
Because if you don't, you like prolong the trial.
You prolong the jury duty.
So what if I just want to leave?
And I just vote whatever the fuck other people were voting for?
Yeah.
So that's why I'm like...
But it's not true.
It depends on the state and the crime.
You can have 8 out of 10 jurors.
Oh, okay.
That's interesting.
But yeah.
I feel like...
If I didn't want to be there, I would just vote...
Like to whatever the fuck the majority was.
Because I just want to leave.
I don't want to argue my case.
I was like, no.
If I see like evidence, I was like, wait a minute.
Maybe he is guilty.
But then everyone's like, no, he is innocent.
And I was like, okay.
Well, I'm not going to argue about that.
I'm not going to argue why I think he's guilty.
All right.
He's innocent.
Okay.
I'm just like, all right.
I got to go home early.
Yay.
I get to go home early.
Woo.
I know someone who intentionally said something offensive to get rejected from jury duty.
I don't know why people bail when they get off work for...
Because for some people, people think jury duty is a crime.
I guess it's working.
That's too much.
I think it, thank you.
I think it's also because like jury duty is also work, because like, you know, like you have to go to somewhere else.
You don't get to stay at home.
Yeah, you don't get to, it's not like you can stay at home for jury duty.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Oh my god, if you know jury nullification is a concept that exists that can get you disqualified from jury duty...
Oh my god, guys!
I gave you an excuse!
Guys!
You can be like, I watched a YouTuber explain jury nullification to me.
And now I know I can have biases with jury duty.
Oh my god.
You're welcome, chat.
I literally gave you the perfect excuse.
Alright, anyway.
I think I'm gonna call it here, guys.
I think I'm gonna call it here.
I had a great time hanging out with all of you, chat.
It was... Your Honor, are you familiar with DokiBurr?
That's about 5,000 people out of jury duty.
And...
Hey, guys!
Tomorrow's a rest day.
I hope you guys enjoyed this little bonus stream.
I had a great time hanging out with all of you guys.
I had a great time hanging out with all of you guys and I hope you guys had a great time chatting with me.
Tomorrow's my rest day!
I most likely will have my schedule out maybe tomorrow.
Tomorrow, most likely.
Because like, it's already really late and I don't really want to post my schedule that late today.
So, I'll work on it today and post it for tomorrow.
But thank you, everybody!
As always, I hope you guys all have a great Easter!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Also, thank you for the super chat, Deadpool!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for the stream, Doki.
It's always a pleasure.
It's always a pleasure to talk to you guys and hang out!
Bye, everybody!
Bye!